[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und dunia
Hayali schönen guten Abend auf eine
Feuerpause will sich Israel weiterhin
nicht einlassen aber die Bodenoffensive
die könnte wohl verschoben werden nicht
aus humanitären Gründen um z.B sichere
fluchtkorridore für die Zivilbevölkerung
im Gazastreifen zu schaffen sondern eher
aus strategischen denn solange die
Bodenoffensive nicht gestartet ist gibt
es Zeit und Raum für Verhandlungen
Verhandlungen über die Freilassung
weiterer Geiseln die sich in den Händen
der Terrorgruppe Hamas befinden gestern
hat das ja dank der Hilfe von Katar und
Ägypten funktioniert Tim
Kröger auf dem Weg zurück in die Heimat
die 85
und die 79jährige Nurit Kuper gestern am
späten Abend nah dem Grenzübergang
zwischen Gaza und Ägypten ein hamasvideo
zeigt die Freilassung sie werden von
Helfern des Roten Kreuzes empfangen die
Terroristen geben sich fürsorglich dabei
ist es gerade einmal zweieinhalb Wochen
her dass 1400 Menschen in Israel brutal
von der Hamas umgebracht wurden heute
vor Reportern erzählt J wie sie auf ein
Motorrad gelegt nach G verschleppt und
dabei geschlagen
wurde ich war in der Hölle keiner hätte
gedacht dass ich so etwas erlebe sie
haben im kibutz gewütet mich haben sie
dann
entfüht mit dem Helikopter werden die
beiden Frauen am frühen Morgen in ein
Krankenhaus nach telaviv gebracht sie
sei in ein gigantisches Tunnelsystem
einem Spinnennetz gleich gebracht worden
sagt lischitz während der Gefangenschaft
aber sein sie gut
bei uns war ein junger Mann der auf
einem Motorrad verschleppt wurde er war
schwer an Händen und Beinen verletzt es
war schrecklich das mit anzusehen ein
Sanitäter hat sich täglich um ihn
gekümmert bis es ihm besser
ging die beiden Ehemänner der Frauen
allerdings sind noch immer in der Hand
der Hamas ebenso wie viele
andere der französische Präsident
Emmanuel macron kam heute bei seinem
Israel besesuch mit Angehörigen von
Geiseln mit französischer
Staatsangehörigkeit zusammen er traf als
erster westlicher Regierungschef
Palästinenser Präsident Abbas und vorher
schon den israelischen Premier Netanyahu
und warb für eine internationale Allianz
im Kampf gegen die Hamas der Kampf muss
gnadenlos sein aber nicht ohne Regel
denn wir sind Demokratien die gegen
Terroristen
kämpfenror
in den vergangenen 24 Stunden haben die
israelischen Streitkräfte nach eigenen
Angaben 400 hamasziele attackiert dabei
soll es laut den von der Hamas
kontrollierten Behörden in Gaza hunderte
Tote gegeben haben unklar ist wann eine
mögliche israelische Bodenoffensive im
Gazastreifen beginnt und ob diese unter
anderem wegen der Verhandlung über
weitere Geiseln verschoben werden könnte
unsere Kämpfer der israelischen Armee
vor Ort sind bereit und entschlossen sie
trainieren weiter für den
laut den Vereinten Nationen sind heute
im Gegensatz zu den vergangenen Tagen
keine weiteren Hilfslieferungen im
Gasastreifen angekommen obwohl die
Bevölkerung dringend darauf angewiesen
sei der Krieg in Israel oder besser
gesagt die unterschiedlichen
Perspektiven auf diesen Krieg haben
heute im UN Sicherheitsrat zu einem
eeklar zwischen Israel und dem un
Generalsekretär geführt guterisch
verurteilte zwar den masterterror erneut
auf schärfste kritisierte dann aber auch
Israels Angriffe auf den Gazastreifen
guterisch sagte die hamasangriffe seien
nicht im luftleeren Raum geschehen das
palästinensische Volk sei 56 Jahre lang
einer erdrückenden Besetzung ausgesetzt
gewesen zudem prangerte er das Vorgehen
Israels
an ich bin sehr besorgt über die klare
Verletzung des internationalen
humanitären Völkerrechts die wir im
Gazastreifen beobacht
um es klar zu sagen keine Partei in
einem bewaffneten Konflikt steht über
dem internationalen humanitären
Gesetz der israelische unbotschafter
forderte daraufhin den Rücktritt des un
Generalsekretärs unsere
uskorrespondentin Claudia Bates hat
diesen eklar verfolgt Claudia der
unbotschafter Israel sagte dann auch
guterisch habe eine Zitat verzerrte und
unmoralische Sicht sah das denn heute
viele so im un-
Sicherheitsrat also das war tatsächlich
eine ungewöhnliche und hitzige
Auseinandersetzung in der UNO heute
guterisch hat da sicherlich für
diplomatische Verhältnisse ziemlich
gepoltert und der israelische
Außenminister Cohen hat ihn ST stark
angegriffen dafür und während dessen
Rede haben dann einige arabische
Delegationen auch den Saal verlassen
andere sind geblieben also wie wurde
diese Auseinandersetzung gesehen ja
guterisch wurde da sicherlich
ungewöhnlich deutlich aber zwei Dinge
dazu zum einen geht es nun auch darum
Israel zu drängen zivile Opfer zu
schonen und maßvoll vorzugehen und das
hat den zum anderen Hintergrund auch die
gemäßigten arabischen Partner weiter
einzubinden und eben nicht zu verlieren
also Solidarität mit Israel ja unbedingt
aber kein blankcochck und das entspricht
ja wenn auch sicher in anderer Wortwahl
schon dem worauf auch die USA und andere
Partner drängen selbst Verteidigung ja
die Hamas ausschalten ja aber keine
Rache Rücksicht auf die Zivilisten in
Gaza unbedingt humanitäre Hilfe
unbedingt noch Zeit eine Freilassung der
Geiseln zu erreichen und natürlich auch
ein klares Kriegsziel wie soll es
eigentlich weitergehen und das fordern
eben ja auch die Partner Israels ein und
damit steht un Generalsekretär guteres
nicht allein da wenn andere sich
vielleicht auch diplomatische ausdrücken
Einschätzungen von Claudia Bates vielen
Dank nach Washington ja und den eklar
wird sicher auch Christoph heusken
verfolgt haben von 2017 bis 2021
ständiger Vertreter der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland bei den Vereinten Nationen
und aktuell Chef der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz einen schönen guten
Abend Herr heusken guten Abend das was
wir da heute gesehen haben war
sicherlich ein ungewöhnlicher Vorgang
oder gehört das dann doch zur Diplomatie
auf offener Bühne dazu nein das hat man
häufiger erlebt es war noch natürlich
sehr stark emotional aber es etwas was
was häufiger häufiger so vorkommt hat
guteres denn recht mit seinen Aussagen
ja guteres ist ein sehr besonderer Mann
und man wirft ihm oft vor dass er nicht
klar genug sich äußert und wenn er
gesagt hat wenn er einerseits verurteilt
hat auf schärfste
die hamasaktion ist das richtig und
gleichzeitig hat er auch recht wenn er
sagt dass das nicht in einem Vakuum
stattgefunden hat und wenn er auf die äh
Besatzung 56 Jahre Besatzung äh der
nenser Gebiete hinweist dann ist genau
das was in geltendem Völkerrecht in uno
Resolution genauso drin steht die letzte
Resolution sagt dass die Besatzung eine
flagrante Verletzung des Völkerrechts
ist Herr heusken große Teile der
arabischen Welt solidarisieren sich ja
mit den Palästinensern zumindest mal
auch auf der Straße auch weil es gegen
zwei Feinde geht gegen Israel und die
USA kann es unter diesen Voraussetzungen
überhaupt zu irgendeiner diplomatischen
Lösung jetzt kommen
ja es es muss zu einer diplomatischen
Lösung kommen es geht natürlich erstmal
darum dass die Geiseln freiommen dem
muss aus meiner Sicht alles
untergeordnet werden und dann muss man
verhindern dass es ein Flächen
Flächenbrand gibt also keinen Einmarsch
der israelischen Truppen im Gazastreifen
und
dann muss man wieder zurückkehren zu
einer diplomatischen Lösung man muss
zurückkehren zur Zweistaatenlösung die
geltenes rechtes und da muss Israel auch
mitmachen das kann man sich derzeit
nicht vorstellen aber das ist der
einzige Ausweg habe ich sie da gerade
richtig verstanden sie sagen israel
sollte besser auf die Bodenoffensive
verzichten auf jeden Fall das sagen alle
das sagen auch die diejenigen die jetzt
mit der Geisel Befreiung zu tun haben
das sagt Qatar das sagt Ägypten die
amerikanischen Präsidenten beiden und
Obama haben aufgrund der Erfahrungen die
sie nach dem 11 September gemacht haben
mit us-operation und den Konsequenzen
geraten dass Isra jetzt nicht aus Zorn
und Hass überreagiert aber wie kann
Israel denn wirklich gesichtswarend aus
dieser Situation wieder herauskommen wir
haben alle die Drohungen und
Ankündigungen verschiedener Israelis aus
der Regierung ja im Ohr wie soll das
gehen ja aber sie sehen doch schon dass
es passiert die
ich glaube dass wir auf ich hoffe dass
wir auf gutem Weg sind sie sie haben ja
gerade selbst gemeldet dass die
Bodenoffensive verschoben worden ist das
passiert auf internationalen Druck und
weil glaube ich auch Israel erkennt dass
es ein Flächenbrand auch für Israel
verheerend wäre und dass dann die die
Aussichten die Israel ja in der letzten
Zeit bekommen hat nämlich Aussöhnung mit
den mit einigen der arabischen und
golfländern dass man darauf dann lange
Zeit wird verzichten müssen die
Aussöhnung z.B mit Saudi-Arabien ist
jetzt erstmal auf Eis gelegt worden
lassen Sie uns noch über die zwei
staatenlösung sprechen aus Europa
inklusive Deutschland ist sie ja oft
gefordert worden passiert es dann aber
nichts ganz im Gegenteil israel hat
seine Siedlung ja dann sogar ausgeweitet
ist das eigentlich auch ein Versagen
Europas ja ich glaube wir haben es
natürlich immer wieder kritisiert wir
haben es dann auch in Resolution des
Sicherheitsrates also völkerrechtlich
rechtlich verbindlich festgehalten
Israel verletzt Völkerrecht mit seinen
Siedlungsbau aber wir haben da keine
entsprechenden Konsequenzen rausgezogen
wir fühlen uns der Sicherheit Israels
als Deutschland verpflichtet und liefern
Waffen unterstützen Israel die Frage ist
ob es zur langfristigen Garantie der
Sicherheit Israels nicht auch gehört
dass wir Israel ermahnen internationales
Recht einzuhalten Herr husgen vor dem 7
Oktober da gab es sie haben es gerade
angesprochen ja diese Annäherung einiger
arabischer Länder an Israel wichtig vor
allen Dingen die Annäherung von
Saudi-Arabien wie gesagt erstmal auf Eis
gelegt lachende Dritte sind das jetzt
Iran Russland und China geht sozusagen
das kühl Destabilisierung des Westens
auf ja ich glaube dass sie da schon die
genannt haben die jetzt davon
profitieren ähm die Annäherung
Saudi-Arabien ä Israel ist jetzt auf Eis
gelegt ähm Iran ist ein wichtiger Akteur
geworden und Russland sieht ähm wie
jetzt äh äh die internationale
Aufmerksamkeit von der Ukraine abrückt
dass sie dort dann auch weiter ihre äh
Aggression fortsetzen können Russland
ähm ist jetzt zusammen mit mit dem Iran
mit Nordkorea und es gibt so eine Achse
des bösens die sie die sich da die sich
da verstärkt und da ist leider der
gegenwärtige Konflikt ist etwas was
was durchaus in russischem Interesse ist
sagt Christoph husken Chef der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz vielen Dank für
Ihre Einschätzung und ihre Zeit sehr
gerne und hier geht geht es jetzt
erstmal weiter mit Nachrichten und mit
dir
Gundula nach der Kollision zweier
Frachtschiffe auf der Nordsee werden
noch immer vier Seeleute vermisst am
frühen Morgen waren die Schiffe aus noch
ungeklärter Ursache zusammengestoßen auf
halber Strecke zwischen Helgoland und
langeok der kleinere Frachter sank kurz
darauf ein Besatzungsmitglied wurde tot
geborgen zwei weitere konnten gerettet
werden die noch vermissten könnten laut
zuständigem Havariekommando in dem
gesunkenen Wrack sein das Schiff hatte
Stahl geladen es ist gleich oben im Bild
und
1300 Kubikmeter Diesel an Bord in
Duisburg haben spezialkräfte der Polizei
einen islamistischen Gefährder in
Gewahrsam genommen wie der Spiegel
berichtet nach Hinweisen eines
ausländischen Geheimdienstes auf ein
mögliches
anschlagsszenario der Festgenommene soll
ein Attentat auf eine pro proisraelische
Veranstaltung geplant haben nach
Medienberichten handelt es sich um einen
vorbestraften is Islamisten der wegen
ismgliedschaft bereits inhaftiert
war seit zwei Monaten ist Chinas
Verteidigungsminister Liang Fu
verschwunden heute wurde er offiziell
entlassen diese Amtsenthebung ist
bereits der zweite Fall schon
Außenminister chingang musste im Juli
seinen Posten räumen auch er war zuvor
wochenlang nicht zu sehen ohne dass
Gründe benannt wurden hat der zuständige
Ausschuss des Volkskongresses die
schidigungen genehmigt ein Nachfolger
für Lee wurde bislang nicht
ernannt in der Ukraine gehen die Kämpfe
mit aller Härte weiter die russischen
Streitkräfte attackieren massiv vor
allem afdi vianka in der Region Donetzk
nach monatelangen Angriffen ist der
strategisch wichtige Ort weitgehend
zerstört gilt aber als Symbol des
ukrainischen Widerstandes die russische
Offensive in der von Russland
völkerrechtswidrig annektierten Region
donetk dauert an den russischen
Streitkräften gelingt es offenbar nicht
dort stationierte ukrainische Truppen
einzukesseln seit 20 Monaten kämpft die
Ukraine jetzt schon gegen Russland
gleichzeitig kämpft sie aber auch um
Investitionen doch wer will in ein Land
investieren das sich im Krieg befindet
wo man sich z.B nicht sicher sein kann
ob das was man aufbaut dann nicht doch
gleich wieder zerstört wird und dessen
wirtschaftsleist im vergangenen Jahr
stark eingebrochen war offensichtlich
gar nicht mal so wenige wie sich heute
auf dem sechsten deutsch-ukrainischen
Wirtschaftsforum in Berlin zeigte das
liegt sicher auch daran dass die
Bundesregierung Risiken für
Investitionen durch garantieinstrumente
abzufedern versucht Peter Aumeier und
Dara Hassan Sade über ein Unternehmen
mit
Weitblick die ukrainische Flagge ganz
oben auf 52 m wie zumtrotz der
fabrikturm ist eine der Lieblingsorte
vom Produktionsleiter Roman panasenko
mit einem weiten Blick über die
Westukraine vom kommenden Jahren will
die deutsche Firma Kreisel hier
Baustoffe wie Mörtel oder Gips
herstellen wir leben in einem Land das
im Krieg ist hier kann jederzeit ein
Angriff stattfinden wir denken nicht
darüber
nach den genauen Ort sollen wir nicht
nennen zu groß das Risiko die
Aufmerksamkeit der Russen und damit die
Raketen auf sich zu lenken auch hier im
Westen neben den Bauarbeitern sind
panasenko und sein Kollege die einzigen
in der Halle stehen erste Maschinen
original verpackt und im Voraus bezahlt
in einem Kriegsgebiet übernehmen
Versicherungen keine
Haftung wir glauben dass das hier
wichtig ist sehr wichtig das Land ist
zerstört und viel ist kaputt wir werden
Baustoffe für den Wiederaufbau
brauchen die Firma Kreisel die zur
bayerischen fixiggruppe gehört hatte
sich nach Kriegsbeginn trotz des Risikos
entschlossen die Fabrik weiterzubauen
und bis heute 5 Millionen Euro
investiert Geschäftsführer Michael Kraus
zuständig für das Osteuropageschäft
macht heute beim deutsch-ukrainischen
Wirtschaftsforum klar
warum für uns war der gamechanger Anfang
des Jahres der Erhalt einer
Bundesgarantie wo sich hier auch
wirklich die Bundesregierung und die
zuständigen Stellen extrem unterstützend
kooperativ und willig gezeigt haben
deutsche Investoren in Ukraine zu
unterstützen 2000 deutsche Firmen
produzieren derzeit in der Ukraine
deutschland ist damit der wichtigste
Wirtschaftspartner innerhalb der EU und
genau diese EU ist es zu der die Ukraine
einmal gehören soll so der Kanzler wer
heute in die Ukraine investiert der
investiert in ein künftiges EU
Mitgliedsland das Teil sein wird unserer
Rechtsgemeinschaft und unseres
Binnenmarktes für Roman panasenko steht
die größte Aufgabe noch bevor der Aufbau
der hochmodernen Anlage ganz ohne
Fachleute denn diese können nicht
einreisen alles soll übers Internet
funktionieren die Geschichte liert uns
wenn erst einmal der Krieg vorbei ist
dann wird sich das Land davon erholen
und genau dafür sind wir mit dieser
Fabrik bestens
vorbereitet für Roman panasenko ist das
hier mehr als nur eine
Fabrik t eine Investition in die Zukunft
und wie sieht die der deutschen
Industrie aus seit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg steht diese ja vermehrt
unter Druck daher soll die Wirtschaft
nun mehr statliche Unterstützung
erhalten aber wer und wie genau
Antworten darauf stehen in dem
Strategiepapier das Robert Harbeck heute
vorgestellt hat vorgestellt nicht
beschlossen kein Gesetzentwurf nur ein
Papier das wurde heute immer und immer
wieder betont doch ausgeschlossen ist
ein Streit wie damals ums sogenannte
heizungsgesetz natürlich ich nicht denn
Harbeck will fast alles erhalten außer
eventuell und ganz vielleicht die
Schuldenbremse den Puls von FDP
Finanzminister Lindner konnten Patrizia
Wiedemeier und Peter Böhmer heute nicht
messen dafür haben sie die Einzelheiten
zur
Strategie er hat für jeden etwas für die
Großkonzerne für den Mittelstand für die
Kleinbetriebe Wirtschaftsminister habck
will mit seiner industriestrategie allen
etwas Gutes tun koste es was es wolle
wir tun aus meiner Sicht noch nicht
genug es ist nicht die Zeit jetzt Hände
in den Schoß zu legen SN es ist die Zeit
mit konkreten Maßnahmen konkret zu
helfen und diese Hilfe in der Wirtschaft
ankommen zu lassen das hoher
Handlungsbedarf besteht dass es keine
rosigen Zeiten sind für die deutsche
Industrie das weiß der Minister das
wissen sie überall im Lande auch bei der
großzinkerei Zink in Gelsenkirchen hier
machen sie Stahlteile rostsicher unter
anderem für lkwauflieger das Unternehmen
hat 2500 Mitarbeiter in 55 europäischen
Standorten oberer Mittelstand Gas und
Strom liefern die Energie wir sehen in
der Politik den Mangel an Sichtbarkeit
dessen wohin man will wir brauchen für
die Zukunft jetzt eine Lösung die
Energie für die Unternehmen für den
energieintensiven Mittelstand vor allen
Dingen bezahlbar macht den von habbeck
geforderten industriestrompreis lehnen
Sie hier ab da ja nur energieintensive
Unternehmen davon profitieren würden
stattdessen fordern sie eine Senkung von
Steuern und Abgaben grundsätzlich sein
Steuern auf den deutschen Strompreis zu
hoch meint auch das Institut der
deutschen Wirtschaft wir haben vor allen
relativ viele verschiedene kleine
Abgaben und Umlagen die eine der größten
davon war auch die EG Umlage die dann im
letzten Jahr abgeschafft wurde das heißt
hier hatten wir schon eine Entlastung
die auch sehr sinnvoll war aber
grundsätzlich ist immer noch relativ
viel zurück in Berlin dass ein
industriestrompreis oder
brückenstrompreis durchsetzbar ist ist
unwahrscheinlich leichter durchsetzbar
sind da folgende Vorschläge des
Wirtschaftsministers es soll
Förderprogramme für den klimaneutralen
Umbau der Wirtschaft geben weniger
Bürokratie schnellere
Genehmigungsverfahren und finanzielle
Anreize für Menschen länger zu arbeiten
wer nach der Rente noch arbeite soll
nicht mehr in die Rentenkasse einzahlen
das heißt mehr Netto zudem müsse mehr in
Forschung investiert und Produkte
möglichst komplett in Deutschland
hergestellt werden 50 Milliarden Euro in
den nächsten vi Jahren will habbeck
ausgeben ohne eine Aufhebung der
Schuldenbremse kaum machbar dass das
unmissverständlich klar ist gilt der
kolationsvertrag inklusive der
Schuldenbremse trotzdem müssen wir
nachdenken ob die Regeln die wir uns in
einer anderen Zeit der ewig lächelnden
Globalisierung des freundlichen
Miteinanders des billigen russischen
Gases gegeben haben für die neue Zeit
passen ich meine sie passen nur bedingt
doch klar ist dass eine Aufhebung der
Schuldenbremse mit der FD wohl nicht zu
machen ist dann nützt es auch nichts
wenn habck am Ende betont die
Bundesregierung arbeite Hand in Hand in
weiten Teilen sei man sich einig in
weiten Teilen ja aber eben nicht bei der
alles entscheidenden Frage bei der
Finanzierung die Reaktionen auf habcks
Pläne sind also gemischt und
grundsätzlich müssen viele Punkte des
Strategiepapiers noch in der
Bundesregierung abgestimmt werden
Valerie Haller wie kommen denn die Pläne
alles in allem in der wir an ja also
tatsächlich ganz unterschiedlich positiv
bewertet wird habix Lageanalyse zum
Industriestandort Deutschland viele
Bedenken aus der Wirtschaft greift er da
auf einigen aber fehlt eine klare
Strategie bei der Umsetzung also bei der
Minderung der Unternehmenssteuern
beispielsweise oder beim Bürokratieabbau
ja und weit auseinander gehen die
Meinungen zum brückenstrompreis den
habbeck favorisiert die einen wollen ihn
andere bemängeln nicht nur die
Großindustrie brauche billigen Strom
sondern alle Unternehmen andere wie die
Familienunternehmer kritisieren
Fördergelder ganz grundsätzlich und
wünschen sich stattdessen die
Milliardensummen eher in notwendige
Reformen wie eine bessere Einwanderung
von Fachkräften zu investieren ja und
noch ist habcks industriestrategie ja
nur ein Plan wie bewerten Ökonomen denn
die
Realisierbarkeit ja also Ökonomen fragen
wie das ganze eigentlich finanziert
werden soll ein Problem dürfte sein die
Koalition Partner mit ins Boot zu holen
Scholz ist skeptisch beim
brückenstrompreis die FDP lehnt ihn ab
Habeck stellt die Schuldenbremse in
Frage mit einer Reform meinen Ökonomen
ist in dieser Legislaturperiode aber
tatsächlich nicht mehr zu rechnen und
die wünschen sich dann tatsächlich
lieber Vorschläge die schon heute im
Rahmen der Möglichkeiten zu finanzieren
sind denn dass die Zeit drängt darin
sind sich alle einig vielen Dank Valerie
nach Frankfurt auch die
eukmission drängt auf Beschleunigung
beim Ausbau der Windkraft sie will
diesen Sektor mit einem Aktionsplan
deutlich voranbringen und zugleich die
heimische Industrie schützen
Genehmigungsverfahren für Windräder
sollen beschleunigt und stärker
digitalisiert werden neue
Vergabekriterien für den Bau von
Windrädern sollen nicht nur den Preis
berücksichtigen sondern Maßnahmen zum
Schutz von Umwelt und
cybersicherheit außerdem geplant eine
Akademie für den windsektor um
Arbeitskräfte zu
gewinnen erstens auch während eines
Krieges kann verhandelt werden wenn man
denn will zweitens trenne Religion von
allem anderen oder grundsätzlicher
ausgedrückt verhandel nicht über Werte
sondern Interessen und drittens wenn du
eine Lösung hast dann zieh einen
Schlussstrich setze also alles auf Null
und schau nicht mehr zurück grob gesagt
haben diese drei Punkte genau heute vor
375 Jahren den 30-jährigen Krieg beendet
und den westfähischen Frieden gebracht
ein kleines Wunder waren doch vier große
europäische Kriege unlösbar miteinander
verflochten mit dem Frieden wurde auch
der Grundstein für ein ziemlich modernes
Prinzip gelegt die Gleichberechtigung
souveräner Staaten unabhängig von ihrer
Macht und Größe und so wurde der
westfähische Frieden bis zum Ende des 18
Jahrhunderts immer wieder als Referenz
für nachfolgende Friedensschlüsse
herangezogen vielleicht auch eine
Referenz für heute Christian
Kirsch Krieg in der Ukraine Krieg in
Bergkarabach Krieg in Gaza die Welt so
scheint es vielen ist zunehmend aus den
Fugen ist Frieden möglich und wenn ja
wie hier haben Sie schon einmal den
gordischen Knoten durchschlagen Münster
nach 30 Jahren Krieg und Chaos
entschieden die Kriegsparteien 1648 sich
wir beschließen dass Frieden sei der
westfähische Friede ein Riesenwerk 5
Jahre lang wurde verhandelt in Münster
und in
osnbrück in der völkerrechtswissenschaft
geht man dazu davon aus dass der
westfähische Friede quasi die Begründung
der staatensouveränität wie wir sie
heute kennen war also das heißt dass wir
seit damals dann das Konzept der
sogenannten Koexistenz vieler
verschiedener souveräner Staaten haben
und das war ganz wichtig um Stabilität
in Europa und auch nachhaltigen Frieden
zu gewährleisten jenseits der
Verhandlungssäle turbte weiter ein Irrer
Krieg am Ende war ein Drittel der
Bevölkerung Mitteleuropas Tod und
trotzdem gelang ein Friedensschluss es
einigten sich Protestanten Katholiken
reformierte aller möglichen europäischen
Mächte von Wien über Frankreich bis
Schweden man verhandelte nur Interessen
keine Moral keine Werte lässt sich etwas
lernen für die Gegenwart also das erste
was man lernen kann und ich glaube
lernen muss ist eher ein bitteres
Lernergebnis nämlich das Verhandeln und
Kriegführen keine scharfe Alternative
ist nicht sozusagen die haben
gleichzeitig Krieg geführt und haben
verhandelt und das denke ich wird im
Falle der Ukraine auch der Fall sein bzw
ist schon der Fall sie verhandeln das
eine oder andere getreideabkommen oder
auch nicht miteinander führen aber
gleichzeitig den Krieg
weiter verhandeln in Zeit des Krieges
das ist offenbar möglich und sei es über
Mittelsmänner auch das war neu vor 375
Jahren und kein Blick zurück auf greu
und Unrecht keine Reparationen das
Ergebnis 150 Jahre relative
Stabilität davon ist der Nahe Osten weit
entfernt was rät der Westfälische
Frieden dass man zusehen muss dass kein
Militär entsteht also sötner im weiteren
Sinn die vom Krieg leben also gerne
zündeln und
ähm alles anstellen damit der Krieg
weitergeht daran allerdings sind
Organisationen wie die Hammers
interessiert Religion und
Interessenpolitik im Nahen Osten
vermengt wenn wir über Frieden
nachdenken wollen dann ist das ganz
wichtig dass man natürlich Konfession
auf der einen Seite aber auch Politik
auf der anderen Seite unbedingt trennen
muss und das ist eine wichtige Lehre die
wir beispielsweise vom westfelischen
Frieden mitnehmen können auch in die
heutige ze it aus der Geschichte lernen
schwierig aber eins zeigt der
westfälische Friedensschluss Frieden zu
schließen ist möglich zentrale Bedingung
man muss es wirklich
wollen Fußball Liebhaber wird die
Champions League sicher gefeht haben
galatasarai Istanbul hat am Abend gegen
Bayern München wer es nicht hören will
muss ich kurz die Ohren zuhalten
verloren und zwar mit 1:3 und das andere
Spiel mit deutscher beteil Union Berlin
gegen Neapel sehen sie später
ausführlich um 030 Uhr in unserem heute
journal Update mit Laura barnik das
war's von uns beiden machen sie es gut
wo auch immer sie sind tschüss und bis
[Musik]
morgen Herz kommen zum Wetter so langsam
hält der Frost auch tagsüber Einzug im
hohen Norden Europas und das bedeutet
der Winter ist nicht mehr ganz so weit
weg aber es ist im Moment bei uns noch
recht mild nicht zu vergleichen mit
Südosteuropa da erreichen wir auch heute
noch mal um 30° aber wir liegen bei
Werten zwischen 5 und 15° denn um uns
herum befinden sich eine Menge Tiefs
auch ein steuerndes tief über dem
Nordatlantik und die sorgen dafür dass
wir in einer milden südwestlichen
Strömung verbleiben diese Tiefs bringen
aber auch eine Menge Regen und so sieht
der Regen heute Nacht zwischen der
Ostsee und den Ostalpen erstmal ab
dahinter kann sich in der Früh im
Südwesten dich der Nebel bilden und dass
die Temperaturen im Moment noch recht
mild sind sehen wir auch daran dass die
Nächte noch frostfrei sind so sinken die
Temperaturen heute Nacht auf 10 bis 4°
morgen liegen wir im zweistelligen
Bereich 11° gibt es in den höheren Lagen
der Mittelgebirge und 16° in
Niederbayern die dicke Winterjacke die
brauchen wir morgen also nicht aber eine
Regenjacke ist durchaus hilfreich denn
dichte Regenwolken breiten sich aus dem
Südwesten aus in etwa bis zu einer Linie
Emsland Vogtland und mit ihnen frischt
auch der Wind aus südlichen Richtungen
deutlich auf im Nordosten bleibt es
trocken mororgen und es gibt sogar einen
freundlichen Streifen zwischen der
Nordsee und dem Erzgebirge mit längeren
sonnigeren Abschnitten die Sonne sieht
man in den nächsten Tagen aber nur
selten es ist stark bewölkt und windig
bei 11 bis 16° und immer wieder ziehen
Regengebiete durch und mit diesen
herbstlichen Aussichten sage ich
tschüss